le vide comme c'est à dire le salon de
votre télévision de demain se tient en
ce moment à cannes alors sur place
toutes les techniques toutes les
nouveautés pour vos foyers sur place
aussi michel chauvière des biens
vous voyez sur ce disque en matière
jesús disques en vinyle sur chaque face
ou ce disque transparent il y à une
demi-heure d'image c'est ce qu'on
appelle le vidéo disque donc au total
une heure d'image c'est voudrait dire
presque la grande est la seule nouveauté
de ce vide comme en fait pas tout à fait
parce que le vidéo disque on en parle
mais c'est un peu comme l'arlésienne on
le voit je vais venir ou tout du moins
on ne le voit yves jamait commercialisé
près ce qui se passe il existe
actuellement sur le marché de systèmes
vidéo et disque le premier
le voici c'est le système à lecture
laser c'est à dire sans contact matériel
avec ce disque les informations c'est à
dire les images sont stockées à la
surface du disque en relief sous forme
de mini aspérités et un faisceau laser
vient lire décoder se lisent donc sans
contact matériel ce qui donne aucun
d'usure une très grande qualité d'image
et les avantages du vidéo disque vous
les avez en voici un an fonctionnement
le lecteur qui est soulevé le poste et
on peut faire des arrêts sur image on
peut faire des marches à franc de marche
arrière
non voilà l'un premier style de vidéo
disque il existe un deuxième vidéo
disque est commercialisé cette année par
les américains basser mais qui lui
s'apparente beaucoup à notre micro
sillon puisque la lecture de l'image se
fait par un contact matériel comme dans
un microsillon avantage de ce système il
est moins cher bien sûr mais il est
sujet évidemment aux traces de doigts et
à l'usure donc de fait
tout le problème est de savoir est ce
que ça sera le laser ou le contact
mécanique qui va l'emporter à ce vide
comme et dans l'avenir en fait je ne
crois pas il y aura bien deux systèmes
concurrents mais simplement celui qui
l'emportera sera celui qui offrira chez
vous à domicile sur un disque le maximum
d'image c'est à dire le maximum de films
dont ce n'est plus la technique qui
commande
mais c'est cette fois ci
programme une dernière nouveauté vous
savez que on augmente la durée de cette
cassette qui est toujours bien vivante
voici la grande nouveauté sur cette
cassette enregistrée sur deux faces
cette fois-ci vous avez quatre heures de
programmes voilà enfin la cassette
longue durée pour vous conviendront sur
la vie comme le salon de la
vidéocommunication dans nos prochaines
éditions de tf1 actualité mais nous
voulions